Guardate l'occhio si muove ci sta
seguendo ci sta guardando
Ah ma
non devi arrivare aiuto qua sopra siamo
tornati a scuola ma questa volta abbiamo
dei nuovi insegnanti cattivi che sono
questi guardateli Che brutte che sono
questo è un nuovissimo gioco in cui
dovremo scappare dalla punizione dei
nuovi insegnanti Mr stinchi e Mrs Skinny
cioè gli occhi a cuoricino
non so se avete notato guarda è a forma
di cuore abitare vedo un cuore
nell'occhio di Mr sink ho notato una
cosa nella lavagna dietro ci sono io
guardate e c'è scritto biggest noob Che
vuol dire Eh insomma Sì tipo una
schiappa Eh in effetti è vero perché
siamo un po' schiappa in questi giochi
Ma vabbè Mettetevi comodi lasciate un
bel mi piace citiamo subito questa
nuovissima Escape Room assieme pronti
difficile Ah qualcuno è caduto qua e più
fai venire qui
guardiamoci intorno dice esploriamo un
po' questa scuola questa classe che ci
sono qui allora ci sono tutti i compiti
Guarda eh dicevamo casa Non voglio
fargli i compiti Non voglio fare i
compiti per casa solo questi lavoro casa
qua c'è la foto di uno degli insegnanti
cattivi professori credo Non lo so e
davanti alla scuola Forse è il figlio o
forse lo studente più bravo di tutti
hanno messo la numero uno non lo so Ma
perché sono così mostri hanno solo un
occhio forse lo scopriremo queste
skateboard ce ne siete uscita qui solo
che ci sono le bar le sbarre Ok dobbiamo
trovare allora un pulsante qualcosa
vediamo allora nella lavagna c'è scritto
i compiti devono essere fatti adesso uno
più uno uguale tre eh chi è stato cosi
Bravo Chi è lo studente modello che è
che ha messo questa soluzione
voglio essere stata iOS ho capito che
non sono molto bravi infatti ma
addirittura questo
c'è scritto gli studenti che non
completeranno i compiti saranno espulsi
Addirittura Beh forse è meglio essere
espulsi da questa scuola cioè insegnate
il maestro è questo aiuto
vediamo cosa c'è scritto qua nella
nostra classe siamo un team Siamo
positivi ci rispettiamo ok Ma avete un
maestro con un'occhioso
pronti Immagino che sia questo il
pulsante perché è l'unico pulsante
Ok proviamo e adesso si è aperta la
porta qui dai scappiamo Innanzitutto
Usciamo da questa classe le coppe Wow è
fatta molto bene queste Escape Room Non
vedo l'ora di esplorarla tutta c'è lui
qui aiuto si sta arrabbiando come dov'è
È qui davanti a te no mi ha preso Ecco
Vitale morto lì fluttuante Vabbè
bruttissimo aiuto Da che parte è
scapposca sembra strano
Oh sono riuscita a scappare da Mr
stinchi e lui è scivolato qui se ce l'ha
fatta Vitale posso farcela Anch'io voi
lasciate un mi piace per portarmi
fortunatamente
mi piace Vediamo se il vostro mi piace
vi porterà fortuna
[Applauso]
sta dormendo per terra perché è corso
tanto con tutta quella pancia Eh mi
viene voglia di saltare
Prova a saltare sulla pancia gli faccio
questo scherzo
non mi fa niente Guarda hahaha
ormai sta dormendo quindi possiamo
portarli sulla pancia addio a Mr sicki
non ti incontreremo più magari troveremo
un altro professor stinchi Beh c'è anche
Miss stinchi l'avete vista Ok abbiamo
l'inizio del gioco c'era Miss stick
Quindi prima o poi la incontreremo
oppure Mister Skin che si sveglierà Vai
nelle tubature qui le condotte d'aria il
labirinto il tuo preferito no no no è
facile attenta però perché ci sono degli
spuntoni ma il problema è che Mr sinchi
Anche laggiù Lo vedete ce la faccio
gigante
quello è un altro Mister sinchi eh
edizione XL gigante e vedi che lui è lì
incastrato nel nel muro Guardate
l'occhio si muove ci sta seguendo ci sta
guardando
aiuto Ehi non mi puoi prendere qualche
detersivo Ciao Ah ah ah meglio scappare
Non farti stritolare del mister sinchi
non credo che stritoli credo che mangi
Ma che trappole ha messo Mr sì quante i
rulli con gli spuntoni immaginati tutti
ci vuole tritare per poi mangiarci Te
l'avevo detto che volevamo mangiarci
Guardati intorno vedi che c'è vedi che
c'è tutto il filo per aprire quella
porta quindi dobbiamo premere quel
bottone per sbloccare la porta così
gigante che non potevi non vederlo
e dovrebbe essersi aperta la porta
adesso c'è un altro pulsante di là
dobbiamo premere anche quello credo
No sei finito nel tritatutto
può avere Vitale vaccinato
Sì si è aperta la porta mi manca l'altro
bottone Allora prova i due potenti Chi
sono i due potenti e non lo so Ah
saranno i bottoni che abbiamo aperto Ah
e perché li chiamano potenti va bene
così tranquilla
è super divertente questo scherzo
rotolato così
sei entrato in un vortice d'aria ma
stranamente mistero salvata non capisco
tutto sto Non lo so È stato un puro casa
Io mi sto facendo sempre invece sei
riuscita a passare si rotolando
Bravissima Vediamo se riusciamo a vedere
Vitale Ragazzi
Fuori è riuscito a vedere Vitale laggiù
no il penultimo mi ha affettato Poverino
Dai facciamo il tifo per chitarra
svitiamo Allora adesso Oh sono passato
Non lo so come ho fatto non lo so
infatti non sono passato
poverino
ciao ciao ciao
Eccolo
è vero Ma non devi arrivare fino
Aiuto sono impazzito qua sopra vado a
scendere
Mi stai frullando È quella ventola
Fermati
Prova a fermarti Come faccio
come si fa Aiuto no Spegnete l'aria
Spegnete l'aria aiuto
è povero Vitale è frullato tutto aiuto
e credo che sì non puoi più salvarti
puoi contattare
Poverino Povera Natale si è buggato nel
ventilatore
finalmente
come sei finito Non ci credo Vitale è
riuscito a passare saluto giù e si
rispro gelato
Ma com'è possibile Eccomi eccomi Eccoli
Guarda non ci credo di nuovo Oh ma come
si fa basta Vabbè io vado ciao ciao
sfracellato 25 volte io nel frattempo
esploro
nel frattempo che aspettiamo che Vitale
provi ancora passare nei laser Wow Qua
ci sono tipo i libri dei mostri di Harry
Potter
Eh
sì ti mangiano Questi libri ovviamente
libri con i denti cosa vuoi che facciano
no
Ehi ce ne sono andata
dopo 25 ore è arrivato Ecco i libri di
Harry Potter che mangiano eh si scrive
Harry Potter I libri mostri sì Questi
libri mangiano come te
no no infatti qui a mangiare sono
riuscito a passare Ciao Anita Ciao ciao
per due ore e mezzo mi dici ciao Cioè mi
si estinchi laggiù vero non la vedo
aiuto e fa paurissima ma questo che
cos'è questo verde Slime
Wow credo che sia qualcosa che che ha
lasciato mi stinchi Allora saltiamo qua
e poi questo si rompevano Sì te lo
volevo era proprio invisibile
Oh missistinchi ma
ragazzi Questa non riesco a prendere
quest'arma cosa Ecco
OK riproviamo a sconfiggere Mr istinti
Tu a che punto sei Ti dico Secondo me ce
l'ho quasi fatta mi mancano solo un paio
di colpi e forse l'ho eliminata Mamma
mia è bruttissima sei pronta
Non ci credere
te guidarla Sì dai una cosa buona che
riesci ti mantiene quello che hai fatto
i colpi che sei riuscita a darle ah
quindi non si ricarica vai vai vai
scappa Però il problema è che quando
scappo si avvicina troppo e se mi giro
dall'altra parte e tu spara il contrario
tipo così sì basta mi giro Ah così
funziona
Ok allora posso riuscire anche io a
scoprire tutti
vorrei capire come hai fatto a
sconfiggerla così velocemente vedi però
c'ha l'occhio cuoricino Bravo Rita ce
l'ho fatta
sta esplodendo Oh yeah Brava brava
Erick Ehi il pavimento l'ha assorbita
tipo
è scomparsa e se si spara che succede
andiamo dai si è aperto una porta qui la
vedi spiaccicare Vitale Vieni vieni che
la missione ancora non è finita finora
mi piace tantissimo perché sia poi alla
fine del video scriveteci il vostro voto
da 1 a 10 Anche noi vi diremo il nostro
voto che cosa sta succedendo qui
forse dobbiamo dobbiamo spostare questi
pannelli vediamo
qua dobbiamo creare questi passaggi
e poi dobbiamo prendere Ah di dobbiamo
Ah vedi perché il pavimento è Lava e
quindi noi dobbiamo Dobbiamo camminare
su questi tubi
per poi andare avanti io ho trovato
un'altra soluzione Ah la soluzione
riprenderlo ogni volta giusto invece di
prenderli tutti questo è un trucchetto
che si è inventato Vitale invece di
andare a prenderli tutti e creare i
passaggi che passi e poi invece di
tornare indietro riprendi questo che è
molto facile
Ottima idea Vitale che c'è sono riuscito
a passare però sono rimasto con questo
tubo in mano
Ok io lo lascio avvisato
invisibile con un tubo invisibile Ok
allora andiamo
di sopra
affrontare anche il figlio quello che
c'è nelle foto
Speriamo di no il bambino puzzone Ma
secondo me non le abbiamo sconfitti del
tutto
oh oh Guarda guarda quante trappole
hanno messo guarda ci sono le palle con
gli spuntoni lì e lì c'è una
calcolatrice gigante
sei una cacca
Sì però è più in tema la calcolatrice
soprattutto se sei in Vitale Beh in
effetti lì c'è una scatola di fagioli e
qualcuno che è morto perché la scatola
di fagioli
Qualcuno ha provato a prendere quella
scatola di fagioli ma non c'è riuscito a
prenderlo
Porca [ __ ]
Io ho sbriciolato tutto no povero Vitale
guardate i pezzetti di Vitale lì
non puoi prenderla quella scatola di
peluche
sticky Hehehe andiamo andiamo sapete
cosa vuol dire stinchi dall'inglese
Praticamente se volete dire a qualcuno
Tu puzzi potete dire you stink Che vuol
dire pupazzi Appunto quindi stinchi
sarebbe tipo puzzone puzza puzza puzza
Quindi abbiamo capito che questi maestri
non si lavano sono un po' puzzolento
mi sembrava strano qua è riuscita a
passare via via via via veloce
attenzione dove ti fermi No vabbè ma ce
l'avevo quasi fatta
pure io è difficilissimo questo stage
Allora riproviamo Allora aspettiamo qua
finché non passa dall'alto passato
ci sei riuscito
Allora avvicinati il più possibile Poi
aspetta Ma che ho detto aspetta non è
spettacolo
Eccolo Vitale si è fermato avvicinati un
po'
Ok adesso aspetta piscinati un po' e poi
ce l'ho fatta Oppure ho visto la palla
passare sopra di te capisci tanti
sei rimasto in vita no non puoi dire che
anche tu
no voglio rifare tutto da casa
Dobbiamo prendere solo un po' di
rincorsa
No no no doppio salto
in queste matite giganti ho appena detto
doppio salto ne ho fatto uno mi sono
stufato No non c'è bisogno del doppio
salto puoi farcela lo stesso Allora
serve solo la rincorsa Sì Eccomi qua ce
l'ho fatta prendere un po' di rincorsa
Godiamoci lo spettacolo di vita ragazzi
non ce la faccio saltare sulle matite
dai Per prima cosa
Aspetta dai quella è più facile è vicina
Sì prendo un po' di ricotta
questo è lontanissimo però mai Insomma
non hai neanche saltato ti sei solo
buttato un altro passo per prendere la
rincorsa invece no vediamo e Riproviamo
Vediamo se ora ce la fa
[Musica]
che cos'era quest'altro Cioè hai
staccato direttamente giù riproviamoci
Non ci credo l'ultimo l'ultimo Beh ma
quante partite ci sono ancora Pensavo
fosse l'ultima Dai ce l'hai quasi fatta
Ora dobbiamo salire in questa scala di
matite
c'è una scala fatta di matite dove ci
porterà Torneremo a scuola sicuramente
dove siamo Guarda che cosa non capisco
perché è tornato in versione
gigantissima
[Musica]
Guarda guarda
a noi stessi Vedi c'è solo la statua
Meno male quindi non ci inseguirà
immagino
Vitale Adoro la super velocità
Stranamente non ci siamo ancora
sfracellati Sì Manca solo una matita
vediamo vediamo ma c'è ancora tanto qui
No vabbè ce la fai È troppo bella questa
Escape Room 247
vediamo no è finita
e io sono avanti questo
trofeo mega robot
invece dobbiamo affrontare il nemico
finale
OK riproviamo Ehi Mr sinchi trasformato
in robot ti sembra super difficile
Guarda quanta vita tantissimo
aiuto
Ok Il trucco è correre
e sparare all'indietro Sì però non ce la
faccio È difficile ma ehi ma sbaglio io
ho ancora la super velocità davvero
Forse per quello che sto riuscendo a
sconfiggerlo Ma pure io forse lo sai
anche tu vai velocissimo Sì per fortuna
Ah bene allora questo per velocità
potevo farcela Guardate la sua vita sta
per finire siamo per sconfiggere Mr Tig
robot mi ha colpito No Stai zitto
ci sono riuscita
E ora come spirituale saltiamogli sulla
pancia
ti ho perso un cancello Ma noi
aspettiamo Vitale Vediamo se ce la
faccio
davanti a noi Wow via via via via Stiamo
uscendo dalla scuola e qua c'è un figo
c'è un parco con degli alberi
sì Aspetta aspetta
dai ti aspetto chi guida dai vai vai
oh oh finalmente
è brava Anita vediamo dove ci porta
questo teletrasporto Sì andiamo a vedere
vediamo questo teletrasporto ci ha
portato in queste Escape Room del
pagliaccio che però noi abbiamo già
fatto ma se non l'avete visto Vi lascio
ora la casellina qua cliccate qua per
vederla Noi diamo vota questa Escape
Room 9 10 io perché mi sono divertito un
sacco con Mister fichi per me nove
perché volevo che avesse più livelli Ma
magari la prossima e ora cliccate su una
di queste quattro caselline eh Buona
visione Ciao